welcome back to las vegas now there are
new mammography guidelines for women who
have had or planned to get the cobit 19
vaccine so let's welcome dr steven yates
of intermountain healthcare the sponsors
of this next segment of course to break
these new national recommendations down
for us hello dr yates hi you are quite
ravishing in your pink for breast cancer
awareness i'm loving these colors on you
well thanks
this is october and we do want to
continue to
to remember that this is breast cancer
awareness absolutely
it is important that women get screened
for breast cancer because early
detection
clearly saves lives absolutely women
with early stage breast cancer their
survival rates greater than 90 percent
right now covet has been a real problem
because we've had a significant drop in
women going for screenings because of
covid
because they're afraid to go into this
they're afraid to go away we saw
it depends on where you look anywhere
from 40 to 60 percent of
screenings were down across the country
because of covid and it's going to take
us a while to catch up so we want you to
go get your vaccine it's safe our
radiation and radiology colleagues are
doing
measures to make sure that women are
protected in a safe and clean
environment to get their screenings
good good now what are the new
guidelines that we're mentioning what
are doctors recommending so well first
first
continue to get your mammograms um at
least every two years for higher risk
women i still think it's best to do it
every year right
if you have had the covet vaccine though
this is the new deal
the copa vaccine can cause some swelling
of the lymph nodes okay under the arm
where you've had the injection
it's a relatively painless process but
that swollen lymph node will look bad on
a mammogram and will scare everybody and
you'll end up having to be
evaluated for the swollen lymph nodes so
if you've had your covert vaccine wait
at least a month after the vaccine
before you go and do your mammogram okay
that is very good advice very good
advice so what is the the overall
you know the overall theme of what you
want to remind women out there so if
they do see this they have to wait well
you know preferably go ahead and get
your
vaccine as soon as possible um and then
a month or so after that go go and get
your mammogram if you're due or past due
okay and i see we're looking at
something right now what is going on on
the screen where are we we walking
through intermountain healthcare
i'm not sure where that is well then
what what is intermountain healthcare
doing to to help this cause oh okay so
well first and foremost intermountain
healthcare is still working hard to make
sure that women
do get their screening mammograms so we
have extra measures in place to identify
those women who are past due to get
those orders in place so they can get
their mammograms and we're working with
our radiology partners to make it easier
for them to get scheduled and get in and
get it get it done in a timely fashion
okay and of course cove it's safe it is
coveted safe yes okay thank you so much
dr yates thank you to intermountain
healthcare for sponsoring this segment
just head to intermountainhealthcare.org
nevada for more information and don't
forget your screenings everybody